we have a speaker Aus
prolor after 3 weeks of Republicans
scrambling to find someone to fill the
top spot in the House of Representatives
white smoke has emerged from the top of
the capital building and Republicans
have elected Rock ribbed conservative
Mike Johnson I mean that sincerely
ordinarily I would say that is a joke
whenever Republicans elect a leader but
that actually they picked a conservative
guy Johnson has a lifetime rating of 92%
from the American conservative Union and
a 90% rating from Heritage action quite
good he's got an A+ rating from Susan
banthony prif America he authored
legislation last year to Outlaw the libs
weird sexual indoctrination of kids and
unlike the previous GOP nominee for
speaker he voted to defend the real
definition of marriage as late as last
December when Joe Biden the Democrats
and the squish Republicans tried
successfully I'm sorry to say to codify
the oberfell samex marriage decision
into law many people had never heard of
Congressman Johnson before yesterday the
only reason I was aware of him is
because of a handful of viral clips that
I had seen of him hurling zingers at
Democrats here is Speaker Johnson
dressing down Joe Biden's Homeland
Security secretary Alejandro mayorcas
I've only got 25 seconds I just say I
don't have time for a question because
you'll be elusive but I just for the
record since we're stating things for
the record I've been in Congress 7 years
I think you're the most dishonest
witness that has ever appeared before
the Judiciary Committee and I think I
speak for a lot of my colleagues this is
such a frustrating exercise for us
because our constituents want answers
they're tired of the open board they're
tired of people dying from overdoses and
it's your fault it's my time Mr chairman
point of order no there's no point of
order in the middle of this this is my
opinion I think it's shared by
Milli based on the standard that the
chairman set out in previous hearings
calling a witness dishonest is over the
line that you drew in a previous
hearing I'm not pulling the words down
it speaks for the American people zinged
owned and now speaker Johnson is not
just about those py onliners some of his
other viral Clips demonstrate that the
guy is clearly intelligent he clearly
does his homework as he showed when he
destroyed the Democrats on the first
impeachment trial of president Trump the
gentleman's recognized I just want to
slow this down and be very methodical
about it because most of us here are
attorneys and in this case we're
supposed to also be finders of fact and
we're supposed to carefully and
objectively analyze the claims against
the record so let's do that there are
two articles to this impeachment
resolution of course abuse of power and
obstruction of justice on the first
Democrats know there is zero direct
evidence in the record of these
proceedings to show that President Trump
engaged in any scheme of any kind as is
alleged in the resolution or that he
intended in his dealings with Ukraine to
influence the 2020 election no
impeachment should ever proceed on the
basis of hearsay and conjecture and
speculation that wouldn't even be
admissible in a local traffic court and
we say that over and over to my friend
Miss jaul there is simply no evidence of
any condition and I guess I need to
repeat the four indisputable facts again
that are in this record because
repetition apparently is really
necessary here first both president and
zalinsky say there was no pressure
exerted number two the July 25th call
transcript showed was no conditionality
between Aid funding and an investigation
number three Ukraine was not aware of
the aid as has been said over and over
here uh that it was being delayed and
number four they never open an
investigation they still received the
aid and they got the meeting this is all
good stuff he's quick he's fast he's
conservative and almost as important he
appears able to unify the party he's got
support from the base he's got support
from the party leader and Incredibly
after the last 3 weeks of congressional
circus not a single Republican in the
house voted against him all's well that
ends well I'm Michael NES this the
Michael no
[Music]
show welcome back to the show this
episode has brought to you buy none
other than good ranchers get great meat
at a secure price get 30 bucks off your
order with my code nolles can Wes go to
goodranchers.com use code nolles
today the cops were called in at a
school district to stop a mother from
showing images from books that are
available to students in the school
district the images were obscene so the
cops actually came in to take the images
away from her and presumably to give
those images to Young children we'll get
to that in a second first though uh to
close up on this speaker this is a
really good thing in a way I guess it
vindicates Matt Gates I was a little
skeptical of gates I was a little
skeptical because I thought yeah Kevin
McCarthy he's not great but he's more
conservative than Ryan he's more
conservative than Boehner he's arguably
more conservative than nuke gingr so he
might be the most conservative speaker
Republicans have had since the 1950s in
Joe Martin which is damning with faint
praise but I thought with a with a razor
thin majority is there any way that
conservatives would be able to get a
more favorable speaker and then when it
looked like we were going to be stuck
with Tom emmer who's a big squish lib I
thought well thanks a lot Matt Gates you
know you get we kick out McCarthy who
was not great but he was fine then you
give us emmer who's terrible well a lot
of lot of good that did us but look Matt
Gates took a big swing here Matt Gates
risked a lot of of his political
credibility and he won at least for now
it remains to be seen because the
speaker of the house is not tasked
merely with writing laws or being really
conservative and consistent or anything
like that he's tasked with unifying the
party raising money whipping votes he's
got to be able to do all those things
we'll see if he can do it but for now we
seem to be in a pretty good position now
Mike Johnson has despite all of this
Goodwill from conservatives he's raised
some eyebr
because as he took on the Gabel for the
first time he announced that his first
order of business would not be to I
don't know bring jobs back to America to
secure the border to bring back
manufacturing to I don't know rev up the
economy again to restore Law and Order
to this that or the other thing that his
first order of business would be to send
money to Israel we're in a time of
extraord crisis right now and the world
needs us to be strong they need us to
remember our Creed and our
admonition turmoil and violence of rock
the Middle East and Eastern Europe we
all know it intentions continue to build
in the Indo Pacific the country demands
strong leadership of this body and we
must not waver uh our our nation's
greatest Ally in the Middle East is
under attack the first bill that I'm
going to bring to this floor in just a
little while will be in support of our
de dear friend Israel and we overdue and
getting that
[Applause]
done we're going to show not only Israel
but the entire world that the barbarism
of Hamas that we have all seen play out
on our television scen screens is
wretched and wrong and we are going to
stand for the good in that
conflict okay this raised a lot of
eyebrows and there were a lot of
conservatives saying hold on I like
Israel well enough BB Netanyahu he seems
like a Charming Man but that's your
first order of business that couldn't be
your second or third order of business
you couldn't do something for America
First isn't that the name of our new
movement is America first and make
America great again why you why is your
first order of business to give money
away to
Israel but I have a little bit of a more
charitable read of what he's doing here
and I think that Mike Johns son is
clearly a clever guy and I think this
was actually a pretty smart move because
one the United States is going to fund
Israel it's just going to
happen the congressmen can vote for it
they cannot vote for it it's not going
to matter they're going to fund Israel
the the American deep state funded
Ukraine over the objections of American
lawmakers and America has a much more
tenuous relationship with Ukraine than
we do with the state of Israel remember
how they did it back in the summer when
Congress didn't want to take another
vote on funding Ukraine so the state
department just found some money the
Pentagon just found some money they said
oh yeah the weapons we gave them that
was actually was cheaper than we said
they were so uh therefore because we
appropriated a certain amount of money
that on our spreadsheets that frees up
some money so whatever they get another
six billion
bucks we would have done that times a
billion with Israel okay Israel just
gets whatever it wants that was always
going to happen especially at a time of
War like this where there are
potentially existential crises in the
Middle East
so what Emer does here is he's looking
at a funding bill that the Democrats
were trying to tie Israel and Ukraine
funding together so Republicans don't
want to vote for Ukraine funding a lot
of them do want to vote for Israel
funding so a darn it we're gonna have to
vote to fund we're gonna have to vote to
fund Ukraine as well we're gonna have to
vote to fund Taiwan we're going to have
to vote for hundred billion dollar in in
military aid that we don't want to vote
on because we feel our hands are tied
because we want to support Israel so
what emmer is doing here is he's saying
we're going to right first thing we're
going to do we're going to vote to fund
Israel and not Ukraine and not make it a
hundred billion dollars and not tie it
all together so it's a it's a clever way
of without saying it explicitly he's not
coming out and saying my first order
business is to defund the Ukraine war
he's saying my first order business is
to fund the Israel war and there boy
defund the Ukraine war the other reason
he's doing this I think is because
Israel is now a wedge issue for democ it
didn't used to be Israel used to be a
unifying issue for both party both
parties know you could be farle Democrat
far right Republican everybody supported
the state of Israel you're seeing cracks
now especially among the Democrats with
the squad with AOC with ilhan Omar
Rashida Talib certainly and others the
the far-left Democrats are saying we
don't like Israel anymore we support
Palestine from The River To The Sea
Hamas will be free and so they're going
to vote against that and it looks really
bad even the White House is dealing with
this Joe Biden's spokesman Karen
jeampier doesn't know how to answer
questions about the Israel Palestine
conflict she gets asked a question about
the White House response to
anti-Semitism she gives an answer about
islamophobia because they don't they're
damned if they do and they're damned if
they don't so by making this the first
order of business everyone's going to be
paying attention to this guy's
first vote as Speaker of the House and
he's going to be able to nail those
Democrats and whatever they do it's G to
it's going to hurt their funding right
now you're seeing a lot of Jewish
funders and we'll get to this hopefully
a little later today if not at least
maybe tomorrow a lot of Jewish funders
of big institutions big universities
saying hey you guys are letting all
these pramas people run wild I'm going
to pull my money I think the same thing
is probably going to happen here with
the Democrats who turn on the state of
Israel they're going to lose money from
pro-israel funders and there are plenty
of pro-israel funders out there or
conversely if the Democrats come out in
favor of voting for this single vote to
fund Israel then they're going to lose a
bunch of support from their base their
base like BLM which is going out there
putting up big signs and and posting
photos to social media in support of
Hamas paragliders so either way they're
getting hammered here and in the
previous version of funding the war the
Democrats could could mify their Base by
saying well look I was voting for
Ukraine war funding but I had to give
some money to Israel even though I
really hate Israel but I had to do it to
fund Ukraine and Taiwan so forgive us
and they would have gotten away with it
here there's some clarity if I were
speaker of the house would I have made
this the first order of
business probably not but it's a pretty
clever strategy and it it makes
me feel pretty confident about the way
that this guy can move levers of power
the way that this guy can find his light
and and move the mechanics of the House
of Representatives it remains to be seen
if he can if he can really succeed but
it's looking good out the gate when you
want to look good you got to check out
genus cell right now go to genucell.com
our friends over at genucel have
launched a new product called genucel 3
which works on your under eye bags and
puffiness genu cell 3 is smooth
luxurious and uses advanced technology
to deliver complex vitamins and minerals
directly to your face for instant
hydration it's like Gatorade for your
skin this new genus cell technology
keeps your skin looking young and
healthy for years to come the genu cell
fall Classics package also includes a
jawline treatment for a firmer neck and
jawline so you can have a nice chiseled
jawline just like me it includes genu
cell's anti- wrinkle moisturizer and
deep Firming Serum get skin ready for
that cold and dry weather and look good
while you're doing it you know I love
this company because they make great
products and because the owner is a
Coptic Christian who left Egypt for the
American dream head on over to jus.com
canw or you can call 800 skin 211 for
extra discounts on this amazing fall
package get results in less than 12
hours the immediate effects are included
for free that is genucell.com
canw or by calling
800 skin
211 speaking of party Unity here even
before this vote took place when Mike
Johnson became the GOP nominee for
speaker as many others have before as
Tom emmer had as Jim Jordan had as Steve
scalise had as obviously Kevin McCarthy
had
before when he became the nominee Trump
came out and he said I back this guy
getting back to Congress we think Mike
Johnson's do really well he's popular
he's smart he's sharp he's going to be
fantastic I think he's going to be a
fantastic speaker I believe that will
happen we'll see what you'll let me know
when I come out I'll be out in a couple
of hours now this was just after Donald
Trump came out against the GOP nominee
Tom
emmer and so if you're Donald Trump
today you're feeling pretty good because
your attack on the GOP nominee for
speaker seems to have worked cuz it
deprived him of the job it would have
been very awkward had had Tom emmer
gotten the nomination then Trump came
out and said this guy's terrible he's
not America First he's not Maga you got
to vote against him and then the guy
becomes speaker all of a sudden Trump
looks pretty weak as the leader of the
party but he looks strong when he killed
his candidacy and he looks strong now
that they finally got Mike Johnson
through with a prominent endorsement
from Donald
Trump so from the perspective of GOP
Unity this is a very good thing and
probably most Republicans are going to
like that not everyone is going to like
that this helps to solidify Donald Trump
as the leader of the
party but I think everybody is going to
like that the GOP at least in some ways
can come together it looks like the GOP
has these irreconcilable irreconcilable
factions but here the GOP was able to
come together they do have a clear
leader in Trump even if a lot of
Republicans don't like him very
much overall that's a win it's a win for
the party it's separately a win for
Trump and it's separately a win for Matt
Gates whose political career was really
on the line and I I was very skeptical
of his move to a McCarthy for now at
least it seems to have paid off now
speaking of Republican presidential
candidates Ronda santis also making big
moves down in Florida he has ordered
Florida schools to shut down the
students for justice in Palestine groups
Governor DeSantis directed Ry Rodriguez
who's the chancellor of the State
University system of Florida to send
notices to UF and uh University of South
Florida notifying them to deactivate
chapters of students for justice in
Palestine and the reason for this
DeSantis argues is that those groups
broke Florida laws about terrorism
here's what Dan Santa said during a holy
Jewish holiday the which is a little
repetitive right holiday is a holy day
anyway I'm nitpicking on language during
a holy Jewish holiday the recognized
terrorist organization Hamas launched an
unprovoked attack on Israel among those
killed were babies women and elderly oh
this is Rodriguez who said this uh to
date approximately 1400 isres have been
killed including 31 American citizens
Governor DeSantis our State University
system and the Florida college system
have condemned these attacks there are
some conservatives here who are
attacking DeSantis for doing this and
they're attacking disantis because they
say this is an attack on Free
Speech I think what DeSantis is doing in
principle is terrific I think this is
great in fact this is exactly the sort
of thing that I call for in my book
speechless controlling words controlling
Minds number one National bestseller
available for you to order right now
wherever fine books are sold this is
exactly the sort of thing that I am
calling for in speechless my only hold
up I didn't even catch myself saying it
that time
speechless no you guys were slow you
didn't expect the third one I got to get
those produced a little faster my only
hold up on what governor DeSantis is
doing here
is it doesn't go far
enough my only holdup here is this is
the first
time this is a relatively modest way for
conservatives to begin wielding
political and cultural power to shape
norms and standards in principle I think
it is a perfectly fine thing to do for
the state to pass laws
against in this case taxpayers
subsidized support for speech promoting
terrorism but does it only apply to
Hamas and Israel this is the only time
we're going to use this kind of a law
when it when it applies to Pro Palestine
protesters what about pro- antifa and
pro BLM protesters antifa is a terror
organization I say this having been the
target of antifa on at least one
occasion when they tried to blow me up
at the University of Pittsburgh last
spring antifa exists to Target
and harm and kill
civilians to achieve political
objectives that is as basic a definition
of terrorism as it is so are we going to
shut down student groups who support
antifa I hope so I hope they use this
law for that purpose what about BLM BLM
is a terror organization it's a little
bit of a harder argument with BLM
because their rhetoric at least is
somewhat softer but BLM in
practice exercised terrorist campaigns
on the United
States BLM in practice attacked
businesses looted robbed killed people
killed dozens of people attacked
civilians to achieve a political
objective that is the most basic
definition of terrorism that is so are
we going to see the government come in
and clamp down using this kind of a law
on BLM I hope
so this is this is a good thing in
principle but if it only applies to this
narrow conflict of Israel versus
Palestine then it seems very suspect it
seems it seems to be haphazardly and and
only narrowly enforced but it's a good
principle the conservatives who are
attacking Dan santis over some attack on
Free Speech or whatever they're they're
misguided here in principle this is the
right thing in principle this is what
conservatives have always done this is
what all societies do because all
societies have standards and Norms this
is certainly what the left has done
toward ends of Injustice and evil we
should use these sorts of tactics in a
just and moral way to achieve good ends
and political flourishing we just got to
do it more often and in more
circumstances now this letter from
Governor Dan santis and the chancellor
of the Florida State system uh it's a
good
letter but when you want to write and
send letters you got to check out
stamps.com right now go to stamps.com
use promo code nolles if you run a small
business you need to plan ahead one of
the best ways to do that is by using
stamps.com for all your mailing and
shipping needs stamps.com lets you print
your own Postage and shipping labels
right from your home or office space
this is incredibly convenient your
shipping labels are ready to go in
minutes so you can get back to running
your business sooner we don't waste time
here at the daily wire we don't have
time to waste time we've used stamps.com
since
2017 when many of you were nothing but a
glint in your father's eye that's right
our office management staff loves
stamps.com because they don't have to
spend hours at the post office anymore
stamps.com offers rates you can't find
anywhere else like up to 84% off USPS
and UPS plus they will automatically
tell you your cheapest and fastest
shipping options for 25 years stamps.com
has been indispensable to over 1 million
businesses you can print postage
wherever you do business no lines no
traffic no waiting they even send you a
free scale so you've got everything you
need to get started set your business up
for Success get started with stamps.com
today sign up with promo code nolles KES
for a special offer that includes a 4-we
free trial plus free postage and a free
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts go to stamps.com Click the
microphone at the top of the page enter
code nolles
kwes folks October is almost over it's
not the summer anymore okay there's no
hiding it pumpkin spice season is upon
us and I am living my PSL lifestyle now
you can too go to dailywire.com shop get
your hands on the limited edition
Michael nolles pumpkin spice candle it's
everything you need to complete the
trifecta to eat
drink and breathe pumpkin
spice don't wait order your candle now
smell me pervading your home entering
your nostrils and your lungs they're
only available during pumpkin spice
season only available at Daily wear.com
sshop
marvelous speaking of wielding
government
power there's a woman who
as a young teenager
[Music]
was now on the one hand the powers that
be are pedaling this stuff out in the
open this is a a Netflix
performer on the other hand though the
powers that be deny it and cover it up
so it they want to Pedal it and they
want to be proud of it and they want to
normalize it for as many people as as
are receptive to it but then when people
are not receptive to it and they start
to push back against it like parents for
instance at their school board meetings
then they've got to deny it like when
this mother came out and she said hey
these are the kind of books and images
and materials that are being presented
to our children to minors this is it she
starts to read it at a Schoolboard
meeting and they send in the cops this
is shameful base and
degrading all seven members of the
committee were also asked to um look at
this image this was in the
book and they all unanimously said that
this and along with that 15
page okay this is in children's
libraries here in Hillsboro County
approved by that committee unanimously
at Plant High it's in multiple schools
there's 10 images of that woman's naked
breast in that book Thank you thank you
next
speaker the cop just comes over he even
he seems kind of sorry about doesn't he
he's
so so ma'am I just I have to take this
down I'm not I'm not allowed to let you
show this smut yeah of course you're not
allowed to to show that
smut
naturally
this is wrong for adults to see and it's
obviously wrong for children to see this
is an issue though where the the parents
need to just keep pushing this is a
total winner you know that when the
Liberals send in the power of the police
to stop them you know that they are on
the right
track now it's time for the final
episode of convicting a murderer if you
are not convinced that Steven Avery is
guilty you will be after the finale
Candace is finally bringing an end to
the nightmare that making a murderer
created they claimed that step Avery was
a victim of corrupt law enforcement
which is what they do they demonized the
police Candace is going to show you who
the real villain is in this final
episode take a look coming up on the
finale of evicting a murderer how were
these filmmakers able to convince so
many people that a man like Steven Avery
is innocent the only story they wanted
to tell was one of police corruption
they were committed to a story she's
doing a good job she's doing a lot of
Investigation they were looking into
things for him doing more than public
defender and my investigator they were
Steven Avery's PR team they convinced
millions of people that they were
innocent emails show that they were
providing plenty of direction that the
averies were to look like a close-knit
family manat County officers were to
look suspicious I think I will forever
be obsessed with the media's ability to
turn a villain into a hero or a hero
into the villain if they could do it to
me they can do it to anybody
[Music]
else you can binge all 10 episodes now
but only if you're a dailywire plus
member so sign up today at dailywire.com
subscribe to watch the entire series my
favorite comment yesterday is from Kevin
who says hey Michael I think blood
transfusions can change personality it's
incumbent on all conservatives to give
more blood that's a great point you know
I I read that survey that study that
showed that organ donations might be
able to change per people's
personalities I know it seems weird but
scientists have seen evidence of this
including blood transfusion so you're
right I guess my first response to that
was man I don't want anything to do with
blood transfusions unless I'm dying in
which case I guess I would probably
accept one but maybe you're right maybe
we can game the system Let's Be Clever
about this we all just start donating
blood and we just make everyone super
conservative it's a great idea unless
it's already conservatives who are
receiving our blood because the libs
have been attacking us which is
increasingly likely well all right let's
see maybe it would have an impact now
speaking of
schools I alluded to this earlier in the
show uh billionaire Ron Lauder of Estee
Lauder has just threatened to pull
funding from upen over Up's Embrace of
anti-Semitism Ron
Lauder is a republican Mega donor he
gives a lot of money to upen is Alma
moer he's the president of the world
Jewish Congress which is an
international organization and he had
already said to pen that he was going to
reexamine his donations here because
upen seems to be allowing the these
these students to support Hamas over the
state of
Israel once again there are some
conservatives here who were saying well
that's that's crazy we need to support
Free Speech even if the students want to
go out and support Hamas or something
like that I think though I I see this
move from Ron Lauder I think this is
brilliant of course the only thing I'm
somewhat scandalized by is why was this
guy giving money to upen in the first
place Ron Lauder is a Conservative
Republican Ron Lauder shouldn't be
supporting the ivy league I mean listen
I don't want to tell billionaires what
to do with their money but there are a
lot of conservative donors who do this
who because they're alumni of schools or
because they've had some relationship
with an institution in the past they
just give money reflexively they got a
lot of money to give it's a rounding
error for them but those organizations
aren't what they used to be they've
become very leftist in recent years and
sometimes the donors don't even realize
it and in this case Ron Lauder a a
Jewish donor is noticing it it because
the institution is
now encouraging students to support
Hamas and because the ivy league broadly
has a problem of professors now
supporting Hamas and Lauder says okay
well I'm pulling my money I think I
think it's the right thing to do for
Lauder to pull his money but I would go
further I think all conservatives should
be acting this way and not only on the
issue of Israel Palestine they should be
acting this way on all sorts of issues
it's not as though universities are just
now uniquely attacking the Jewish state
universities for years for decades have
attacked white people they they've held
courses and seminars about how we need
to abolish whiteness why are white
people still giving money to the
universities the universities have come
out explicitly and said we don't like
white people we think it's bad to be a
white person we want to punish white
people we want to discriminate against
white people as a matter of University
policy for one and as a matter of law in
our country and certainly as a matter of
cultural practice so why are white
people giving money to these
universities often it's white liberals
who are donating anyway that's a very
bad white people should not be giving
money to institutions that explicitly
hate white people that's crazy what
about Christians these universities are
almost all extremely anti-christian
Christians should pull their funding why
on Earth are we giving money to
anti-christian
organizations all these groups are very
anti-male in the name of feminism they
attack men they say men are toxic and M
why are men giving money to these
organizations all of these groups
promote all sorts of weird sex stuff
they're explicitly anti-h heterosexual
they're anti-am they're anti-marriage
why are normal people in normal
marriages with normal sexual practices
why are they giving money to these
groups let's all take a lesson from Ron
Lauder here Ron Lauder being extremely
involved in Jewish activism is obviously
keenly tuned in to what's going on in
the Israel Palestine conflict and he
says I'm pulling my money because you're
you're not being nice to the
Jews yeah we should apply that principle
to so many other identity categories and
we don't do that but we certainly should
it is suicide to me when I see
conservatives giving money to these
extremely leftist
organizations and it applies to any
number of categories of identity groups
now speaking of Israel and the war in
the Middle East uh Israel was supposed
to invade Gaza right away that was the
plan right after the terror attack that
killed over a thousand Israelis and
harmed a lot of other people and
resulted in lots of Innocence very young
and elderly being killed Israel was
going to invade Gaza then they delayed
and Israel has just agreed to delay
again this inspected expected invasion
of Gaza so that the US can Rush some
more missiles and missile defenses to
the region to protect US troops there is
what the Wall Street Journal is
reporting us officials have persuaded
the state of Israel to hold off until US
Air Defense systems can be placed in the
region for the protection of US troops
who are stationed in Iraq and Syria and
elsewhere and presumably for the defense
of of the Israeli State as well which
the United States has protected for a
long
time I get why the United States
government is asking for this I guess
though I don't really trust Joe Biden or
much of the top rat at the Pentagon to
conduct our foreign policy but I think
this is a bad move I think that if the
state of Israel is going to attack Gaza
which it has to I think it certainly is
well within its rights to attack Gaza
after the terror attack launched by the
elected Authority that governs
Gaza if it's going to happen it's got to
happen quickly because every day that
this gets delayed is the state of Israel
loses public
support immediately after the terror
attack Israel had widespread if not
unanimous public support
but every day that just the shelling
goes on and the church gets destroyed
because of an Israeli missile and a
hospital is destroyed actually maybe
likely from a Palestinian missile but it
doesn't matter in the public view people
are are not going to believe that or
it's Israel is going to lose public
support by the day
and furthermore every day this goes on
and the US Russ's more defense and
weapon systems over to the Middle East
maybe over to the state of Israel it
further implicates the United States in
this war and it pulls us into this war
more and more which very few Americans
want very very few Americans want the
United States to get involved in a
protracted ground war in the Middle East
because of a conflict in Israel
Palestine that has gone back over a
century that really dates back Millennia
very few people who are who are pushing
for that a lot of people want to defend
the Jewish State meaning we send money
we protect them to diplomatically we do
whatever but there is a very low
appetite in in America for US troops to
get involved in another endless war in
the Middle East every day this goes on
every new missile system that the United
States sends over there the more likely
the US gets implicated in this War I I
see why Israel is doing it and frankly
Netanyahu might be doing this because
the US says we're gonna we're gonna
force you to delay the invasion of Gaza
but if it's going to
happen I don't
I don't see how the position of Israel
or the United States improves by
delaying things if it is going to happen
anyway in fact it just seems to make
everything worse and more dangerous
which is the which is the Joe Biden
foreign policy so of course that was the
case now speaking of war in US
troops we have got a Medal of Honor
recipient coming on this show in the
member block the rest of the show
continues now you do not want to miss it
become a member use code noes kwes at
checkout for 2 months free on all annual
[Music]
plans